over the last week myself and my friends
decided to come together and transform
some of dragon ball super's artwork into
[Music]
dragon ball z an art style that's
captured the hearts and minds of an
entire generation but like any form of
art style changes over time trends
develop and the evolution of
technologies offer new approaches never
before seen each year oda's modern works
look wildly different from his earlier
days and akira toriyama style has
majorly shifted a minimum of three times
over the past three decades with a bunch
of subtle changes hidden in the midst of
it all and so as a result of that change
dragon balls anime was adapted
accordingly in fact it had arguably seen
even more drastic changes due to the
numerous character designers colour
designers and compositing choices the
series has implemented over the passing
decades as they try to bring to life
akira toriyama's ever changing designs
dragon ball z and dragon ball super
showcase a pretty major difference in
approach despite sharing so many staff
so focusing on these two shows seems to
make the most sense to me however before
we dive into the drawing i'm gonna need
some help with this video our team
assemble
joining me first on this journey of
dbzeifying the super series is anime aj
on top of being a terrific artist in his
own right there are a few that can match
his knowledge of the industry and he's a
whiz with photoshop which will be
invaluable during this video as you'll
soon come to see next up is editor san
he's our support player he's another
amazing artist and in addition to
editing this entire video for us we'll
be providing his own corrections to our
work as well as some artwork of his own
and finally our heavy hitter trev i
don't think i know a single person on
the planet that knows how to draw dragon
ball better than this guy his knowledge
of the various styles and shading
principles proved to be crucial in the
production of this video and so now that
we're familiar with the team it's time
to start drawing first up
[Music]
effectively throughout this video we'll
be redrawing frames from super in the
style of dragon ball z's best while i
hopefully do a good job of explaining
how the production and stylistic
approaches have transformed over the
past few decades and boy do i have my
hands full with this one this still is
taken from the battle of god's portion
of the story and as seen in it trunks
and goten stand front and center as
little blobby babies i chose this one to
tackle first specifically because
like many of you something that's really
bothered me about super's modern design
approach has been well they look about
five and six years old when in reality
they should be about 11 and 12
respectfully but instead they look
younger than they were four years in the
past during the boo arc and so using
gohan's training with goku in the
chamber and the future trunks special as
reference i started the difficult
process of aging up the two young tykes
into the almost teenagers they should be
and to be perfectly honest of all the
drawings i did for this video this was
by far the most difficult of the two i
found trunks the easiest as he already
had an aged up design around this age
but the closest thing i could find to an
11 year old goten was his brother gohan
from dragon ball z or goten himself at
the end of z and in the end i settled on
a combination of the two i kept the
close the same which meant goten looked
like
and trunks looked like a mechanic which
i suppose is kind of fitting and okay
now comes my favorite part right now we
have a drawing in the style of dragon
ball z but the image looks too clean to
be from the 90s and aj time to work your
magic with photoshop apply dbz time
travel filter now
and voila there you have it an aged
looking recreation of a super still in
the style and presentation format of
dragon ball z next up
[Music]
it's trev
this was one i was particularly excited
for and in typical trev fashion has
exceeded my expectations akira
toriyama's designs have changed
considerably over the years and not just
between dbz and super piccolo's first
appearance in the 23rd tenkaichi budokai
stands in stark contrast with piccolo
himself from the buu saga and with gohan
the same is true numerous characters
newly introduced to the series are on
the skinnier side which was most
definitely not the case with z in the
process gohan ended up losing some
muscle mass and although narratively you
can justify it in the film there's still
a number of design elements that need
changing throughout the process trev's
mission was to bring back more refined
muscle shapes angular linework and the
layered shading that defined much of the
buu saga so far it's looking amazing and
now all we have to do is apply the
magical chains of filters and
this looks like it could have come out
during the 90s now but no time to stop
and admire we're already moving on to
the next drawing
and the artist tackling that one is
oh it's me again of the illustrations i
contributed and worked on during this
video i think this is the one that
turned out the absolute best the purpose
of this video of course isn't to point
out bad artwork and so for the majority
of these drawings the illustrations
themselves are very faithful to the
model sheets and pretty confident
overall the purpose of this video
instead is simply to highlight how
different approaches through color and
design philosophies impact the creation
of a series along with more technical
elements we'll touch on later frost was
a character i knew was begging for this
specific treatment because he's part of
frieza's race the reference is already
there and by the way the drawings in
super don't look this way because the
artist can't draw it's specifically
because they are following design sheets
that yield this sort of output
attempting to emulate toriyama's shift
in style tadayoshi yamamuro began to
adjust his designs from the old days in
pretty major ways some parts are more
angular some are sharper but it all
totals up to a drastically different
look compared to z i changed everything
on this drawing from the eyes to the
shading making it all appear more
muscular helped plenty by three-tone
shading and to achieve the final color
we landed on for him we actually just
found an old animation cell and tweaked
it in photoshop until we got the blue
color we wanted but yeah this is the end
result time to add the finishing touches
with aj's dbz filter and
there you have it frost drawn in a
classic style looking as though he was
conceived of during the 90s but no time
to dwell in frost it's time for hit next
and drawing him we have
trev once more
personally i love hit's design and
something you might have noticed at this
point in the video is the textured
effect we've added to all the final
recreated shots that's not just a quirky
creative choice it's art imitating life
dragon ball z was shot on 16 millimeter
film which adds a very intense texture
to the artwork adding to the tangible
feeling you get from cell era anime it's
one of many aspects that gives it that
classic feel but it's also a really
cheap film stock typically associated
with grungier looking films due to its
grainy intensity so there's a lot more
grit to it compared to larger format 35
millimeter dragon ball super on the
other hand as many of you could have
guessed is colored digitally and put
together using adobe after effects
creating this 100 clean cut look without
additional processing many people like
this but personally i think it often
looks quite flat in comparison when
super's director changed from the
universe survival arc onwards the
replacement tatsuya nagamine saw fit to
change this by adding an artificial
grain layer to help add texture to the
image along with stronger contrast
throughout although still clearly
rocking a modern aesthetic this helped
evoke memories of an older era trev's
hit here looks great the line weight is
varied the aspect ratio is 4 3 and the
colors are consistent with kamehamehas
used earlier in the series now all we
have to do is add that film grain to the
image and
presto it really helps to elevate the
piece by adding the final touches
up next
trev again with goku kaioken blue trev
is all over this video with his amazing
artwork and this was one i was very
excited to see we're all familiar with
super saiyan blue kaioken by now but
sourcing the colours for this one was
quite challenging normally we'd scarred
the series and it's movies for
comparable color palettes to use but
there wasn't ever a combination of
colors like this used in the series
particularly within auras in dragon ball
z auras were almost all hand painted
with strong contrast values that kept
the pictures underneath strongly visible
although they are hand drawn for super
saiyan in dragon ball super they're
digitally composited with very intense
glowy bloom new auras like ultra
instinct and super saiyan blue are
technically hand drawn in that their
placement and movement is decided by the
animators but the actual appearance is
all digitally generated usually creating
this overwhelming effect that makes the
black lines underneath difficult to see
this is precisely something we're
looking to avoid here with this
particular piece and so we had to try to
brainstorm how we thought this might
have been approached back in the day in
the end only minor changes needed to be
made to the anatomy and the face was
altered slightly but what really made
this come together in the end was the
team's choice of color which really
makes or breaks a reimagining like this
in the end we opted for a more muted and
minimalistic approach compared to the
original and i think it looks all the
better for it we're all very pleased
with how this one turned out alright
time for tread to take a break now next
up we have
aj yeah but first a quick word from our
sponsor
hey kid are you still eating normal on
healthy cereal the kind i gave up on
before it made me fat well i found a
solution i partnered with magic spoon to
bring you the healthiest cereal for
adult men adult women and adult children
yes adult children now i know what
you're thinking what do i know about
cereal why are you screaming at me
what's in this stuff first of all don't
ever speak to me like that again
secondly
and thirdly magic spoon is
magic it tastes just like normal regular
cereal except it's low carb has zero
sugar zero gluten zero grain zero wheat
zero soy zero problems which
means you can't get fat eating this that
is unless you buy and eat a metric ton
of the stuff in which case please use
the referral link in the description and
get as fat as you want each serving is
only 140 calories four net grams of
carbohydrates and 14 heaping republican
voting gun toten grams of all american
protein and as if you needed more
reasons to buy this product it
comes in more delicious flavors than
pretty much any cereal i can think of
click the link below to grab a variety
pack and try it today and be sure to use
the promo code not mark at checkout to
get five dollars off any order or go to
magicspoon.com
not mark and if you dare not like it for
any reason they'll refund your money no
questions asked so what are you waiting
for magic sprue it's
[Music]
reimagining goku black rose and actually
using a tablet for once this one was
arguably the most challenging to get
right the new auras found on godly forms
in dragon ball super are very bright and
very glowy with a bunch of light bleed
all over and this debut of goku black
rose form is one of the most extreme
examples in the entire series this
intensely bright approach just isn't
really a thing in dragon ball z outside
of rare moments like goku's first super
saiyan transformation so trying to make
this look right was really difficult aj
decided to apply the style of kesuke
matsunaga for this rendition of goku
black who was one of the most modern
looking animators in the entire series
and a fan favorite during the boo arc
defined under chins prominent noses
unique smiles it has it all and when
viewed in the style of a regular
animation cell the plastic sheet that
gets painted and photographed for the
show it looks very convincing throwing
in the background and starting to layer
on auras and bits of lighting does bring
the image together more but that old
school look starts to vanish a little if
we compare it back to the kaioken blue
image where we opted to forego any
additional lighting the difference in
authenticity is very clear maybe modern
dragon ball cutting back on the
overwhelming glow is the key to
achieving that familiar look let me know
what you think for now though age is up
for yet another reimagining this time
with future trunks is super saiyan rage
this recreation is tied first with
another drawing you've yet to see as my
favorite within this video and it
achieved that status in part due to the
great artwork on display but also
through a very underrated approach of
dragon ball's design process color
design for shows like dragon ball the
color design can make or break the
product and in the case of dragon ball
super's color design it certainly didn't
do it any favors bold vibrant and
saturated colors coat the series wall to
wall and in my opinion it devalues a lot
of the artwork on display for example
here's a still from the dragon ball
special yo sun goku and his friends
return this special was widely praised
by fans as some great work from
tadeoshimamura before he started working
on super and people stopped praising him
but we think this is largely due to the
color choices of super and not entirely
to do with the artwork itself let's take
that existing still a vegeta from the
special and now let's give him the super
color scheme just like that it
immediately looks like super and the
drawing for the most part is undercut by
those colors following super's
production the film dragon ball super
broly abandoned its old color designer
and brought in rumiko nagai who adopted
a color scheme very similar to z pinker
skin and orange ghee and generally more
pastelly colors all around a lot of
people might not recognize that because
most people consume either faded or
tinted versions of the story through the
dragon boxes and level sets or over
contrasted and saturated versions of the
funimation dvd and blu-ray releases
neither of which faithfully display the
series as it was initially intended heck
if we do the inverse of the vegeta
example i showed you earlier and shift
the colors from broly to super you get
the same effect stills that looked like
they were from dragon ball super it
really can't be understated just how
much of an impact color has on our
perception of tone as an audience and
this piece aj has been working on is a
terrific example of that gone are the
blown out lines and saturated colors and
now we have a line ways and color
palette consistent with the classic
series way to go aj next up
me
this fuse zamasu was the first drawing i
tackled for the video and i was
immensely pleased with how it turned out
in the end although it was rocky from
time to time thankfully i had a nice
reference for some evil looking kai eyes
in z if you cast your minds back to the
supreme kai's very first scene in the
series he's depicted as this sly looking
individual with his intentions as of yet
in the series still unknown to us he
made for the perfect reference point for
me to utilize and i think i managed to
achieve that the hair was probably the
biggest hurdle in the end but i managed
it thankfully due to its similarities to
goku's super saiyan hair the aspect
ratio of this era of dragon ball meant
that i could show more of his halo and
hair on the colour front i actually
regret giving him three toned shading
for non-close-up shots like this
normally a third shading tone tends to
take away from the final image i think
with much of z using only two tones when
characters are depicted farther away but
in the end i was happy with how it all
turned out specifically after the
filters were applied and there you have
it if zamasu had been conceived of
during the 90s maybe he would have
looked a little like this
next up
editor sand with
caulifla
this is another classic scenario of
dragon ball super yielding very skinny
new characters thanks to toriyama's
ever-changing art style in the past
saiyans were depicted as being savage
muscle-bound brutes women included and
with this venture we aim to beef up
caulifla to bring her more in line with
the saiyan women found in places like
the bardock special in dragon ball super
they had a tendency to draw newer
characters with bigger heads and
different muscle shapes and so bringing
everything together into one consistent
design philosophy was a lot of fun
personally i find it very difficult to
draw female dragon ball characters as
they tend to require very different
approaches to their male counterparts
furthermore characters that have less
detail in the face are for me the most
difficult to draw as they're so much
more unforgiving do even one thing wrong
and the entire piece is off but in the
end with the right colors the right
linework and the correct drawing
philosophy caulifla is brought to life
in a classic fashion all we need is the
filter and
there you have it classic caulifla
now we move on to the final drawing and
taking us home we have trev tackling
ultra instinct goku a tall order for any
artist
contrary to popular belief both super
and z are hand drawn on paper first but
there's a difference in the final result
for a few reasons super's hand-drawn
genga the key frames that make up the
animation are scanned in and digitally
processed which can result in sterile
looking work if the lines aren't treated
properly for example early
pre-tournament of power dragon ball
super headlines with almost no thickness
variation at all this can result in
drawings looking a little flat or
lifeless by comparison thankfully the
tournament of power fixed this to a
degree with a filter that introduced
varied line weight and then dragon ball
super broly took that a step further by
making it look intentionally inky this
all stands in direct contrast to z where
the final cleanup drawing the doga is
still on paper and literally photocopied
directly onto the cell preserving all
the tangible nuances of the drawing
defects and all like gaps in the
linework being present for example and
very similar to the kaioken and goku
black shots earlier a major challenge
with this piece was how to best depict a
modern aura in the old style truth be
told we went through a number of
alterations and variations but in the
end we agreed a more standard aura best
suited the new look and there you have
it a classic looking ultra instant goku
amazing work trev and everyone in this
video
if i conveyed anything in this video i
hope it's that dragon ball largely
didn't change its style between the
early 2000s and dragon ball super's
first few arcs those same digital color
approaches to a digital finish pipeline
crept into this new series and it took a
long time for a director like nagamine
to come in and overhaul the show its
production issues in terms of scheduling
are well documented but aspects like
color design and compositing are just as
important to achieving good results and
i hope we've demonstrated that today
nagamine continued to overhaul the
series and as a result dragon ball super
broly level things up further with a new
character and color designer that feels
both nostalgic and modern even as the
series veers off into the realm of cg
for the new movies the color choices for
superheroes teaser trailer looks great
with the same inky linework that appears
to be here to stay and with a new 2d
teaser showing dragon ball super broly
designer shintani keeping up with the
same aesthetic it seems as though modern
dragon ball has finally hit a point
where it feels not only refreshed but
makes use of the strengths the more
classic approaches offered the story
back in the day that we all know and
love unless your dragon ball heroes
special thanks to trev aj and editor
sand for helping with the artwork in
this video i literally couldn't have
done it without them and so i highly
encourage you all to check out their
twitters and socials in the description
down below if you want to see more
artwork and content from them they're
immensely talented and this won't be the
last time you see them either next week
we're going to tackle even more of
super's artwork and transform it into
dragon ball z style if you don't want to
miss it consider subscribing but until
then i've been totally not mark i'll see
you all next weekend thank you so much
for watching
[Music]
hmm
you